this car is a first for British and
European motorways
press the blue Crews on
speed
and
take the hands off
there's a real feeling of sickness in
your stomach
and you feel like you might go to either
side of the road but you don't it's
legal to let go but you can't look away
really off because I'm just not looking
at the road
and the alarm sounds it wants me to
watch the road ahead
it's almost driverless
driving isn't it but not quite it's
almost yeah so we're taking care of the
acceleration braking steering we figure
out where the lane markers are we react
to it
and
you don't need to keep your hands in the
near region of the steering wheel but
we expect you to watch the road and
control the situation the tech is on
board the newest electric Ford Mustang
Mac e nearly 200 000 drivers in the U.S
and Canada have used it without incident
but some have concerns we are very
worried that this is happening on a
piecemeal basis a car maker by car maker
basis the key thing for us is ensuring
that the drivers themselves who buy
these cars know exactly what the car can
and cannot do and at the moment that's
all down to Ford and there's no
government intervention and no
government training the government says
it shows the UK is at the Forefront of
innovation and Ford plans to roll out
blue cruise to more of its Vehicles so
what is the point of the Innovation so
if anyone who's got adaptive cruise
control on their vehicle this is the
next step step on for that I think it's
all about just making the whole Driving
Experience better and easier for our
customers hands-free is is free at first
then you'll have to like it enough to
pay 17 pounds 99 a month for it
Lisa dailed Sky News Warwickshire